nitrogen often gets less attention than
carbon or oxygen but nitrogen is very
important to life as well and like
carbon and oxygen it cycles through our
biosphere now one thing that's maybe
surprising about nitrogen if you haven't
studied it much is that it is very very
common in our atmosphere 78
of our atmosphere is molecular nitrogen
so it's in the form of n2 so this right
over here is molecular nitrogen you have
two
nitrogen atoms covalently bonded to each
other
now unlike carbon which can be directly
fixed by plants in the carbon cycle
video we talk about how autotrophs like
plants can take light energy and use
that to fix carbon from the air into a
solid form and store that energy in
those carbon-carbon bonds
nitrogen cannot be directly fixed by
complex organisms like plants instead
the key actor that fixes the nitrogen
from the air so you have all of these n2
molecules
in the air here the actors here aren't
plants but prokaryotes
like bacteria so let me draw some soil
here and the bacteria could be in a
bunch of different places but you could
have a bacteria in this soil
i'll draw a little bit bigger so you can
see it so prokaryotes
right over here there's the bacteria and
certain types of bacteria are capable
and prokaryotes are capable of fixing
nitrogen so what they're able to do is
they're able to take that n2 and turn it
into a form that is more usable by
complex organisms like plants so this is
the bacteria right over here
so that's the bacteria that's just a
little circular strand of dna i could
draw other i could make it more
complicated but let me just do it like
this bacteria
is able to fix that n2 and take it to
ammonia nh3
and it's this ammonia
it's this ammonia that is really useful
for plants and other complex organisms
so this right over here
so as the plant in the in the video on
the carbon cycle we talk about how
plants fix carbon that carbons make up
carbon makes up a large part of organic
molecules but many important organic
molecules also need nitrogen and these
are examples of organic molecules that
you'll find in plants and you'll find
them in many different types of
organisms so this right over here is an
amino acid
amino
acid
you see the nitrogen right over there
this right over here is our good old
friend atp adenosine triphosphate the
store the quick store of energy in
biological systems you see the nitrogen
in blue right over here this is the
famous
dna
deoxyribonucleic acid and you see the
nitrogens throughout this macromolecule
so nitrogen is essential for life but
the step of fixing that nitrogen that's
done by bacteria which can then produce
the ammonia which is then usable by
plants and then by eating the plants
things like you and me can get that
nitrogen into our systems now it's not
just a one-way street that is we're just
going from the nitrogen the atmosphere
and it gets fixed by prokaryotes and
then it that gets
used and that gets
turned into ammonia and gets used by
high organisms because then eventually
all of it would would get depleted as an
organism dies
as an orgasm dies so let's say this is a
dead organism it could be a bacteria but
i'll do a higher organism a
multicellular one this is a dead plant
here i don't want to draw dead animals
it's
more morbid
so let's say this is a dead plant there
and when it gets decomposed and there
are many different types of bacteria
even though i might draw them looking
kind of the same let's say this is
another bacteria in orange as these
bacteria digest these plants they're
able to they could take some of the
nitrogen and break them down into
nitrites and nitrates these are these
are molecules involving a nitrogen
bonded to two or
three oxygens
and they could take them back to ammonia
so we could go back
so we could have bacteria that take us
back to ammonia or eventually by
converting the nitrogen into nitrites
and nitrates we could go back
we could go back
to
that molecular nitrogen that n2 that
then gets released back
in to the atmosphere
so or it could get even it's you know it
could get stored in other ways as well
but in general as you see here this
pattern that we have these elements that
are essential for life they don't just
disappear or form out of nowhere they're
constantly being recycled in our
biosphere and nitrogen doesn't get as
much attention as carbon or oxygen but
it is essential for life in fact when
you look at
especially plants and growing plants and
you think about fertilizer fertilizer is
something that if you think if you add
it to a plant it's going to grow more so
without it it kind of limits how fast a
plant can grow a lot of fertilizer is
going to have nitrogen and another video
we're going to talk about phosphorus and
that phosphorus and nitrogen and their
availability in the soil is often a rate
limiting factor for plants and you know
that because if you add more nitrogen or
that phosphorus will add more ammonia to
that soil you're going to the plants are
going to grow faster